the commonwealth of fallout 4 is full of
desolate wandering interesting
characters who you can then kill and
loot it's also home to some locations
that wouldn't be out of place in Freddy
Krueger's ambient fueled nightmares it
doesn't matter how decked out your power
armor is because fear can penetrate the
hardest of suits grab your security
blanket dug under the covers and check
under the bed for feral ghouls as we
dive into these pulse raising locations
number 1 swans pond oh it's not very
scary on the surface swans pond near
Boston Common is terrifying for another
reason you might think you're just
passing by a pond with nothing
noteworthy around but then it happens
the ground begins to rumble
you turn around just in time to see the
ugly face of one of the game's unique
super mutant behemoths named Swan who
incidentally has the big plastic Swan
strapped to his shoulder if you don't
become a crater within the first few
seconds of encountering him you might
just be able to take him down to get a
legendary furious power fist weapon that
is if you don't crap your pants when you
first encounter them number 2 Suffolk
County charter school a school in the
middle of a post-apocalyptic wasteland
how creepy could it be of course the
answer is very very creepy indeed what
makes Suffolk County Charter School
unique as the school's history if you
look into the background of the school
you'll find out how it was part of a
government experiment called the
nutritional alternative paste program
that means the school swapped out it's
rubbery chicken nuggets and crappy pizza
for pink sludge so in other words it was
not grade still apparently the paste
increased aggression in the students and
actually turned their skin a little pink
well that's pretty gross fans of Fallout
are no stranger to seeing the results of
experiments gone awry but there's
something more unnerving than usual to
walk into the school and see all the
feral ghouls with bubblegum pink skin
number 3 Dunwich borers ah the Dunwich
borers a place where hope goes to die
and where your sense of reality goes to
get warped if you're at all familiar
with the works an HP Lovecraft then you
might have picked up on the reference to
the Dunwich horror a short story written
in 1928 you might also recognize the
name Dunwich because it appeared in
fallout 3 in the form of the Dunwich
building a dungeon that featured a lot
of supernatural phenomena and was
arguably the creepiest place in the
capital wasteland the Dunwich borers is
a dig site that looks innocent enough or
as innocent as a place in a fallout game
yet
but it hides a terrible secret as you
clamber deeper into the pit you'll
witness supernatural flashbacks akin to
the one from the Dunwich building and a
bunch of feral ghouls trying to gnaw
your face off if you venture deeper you
can find a dagger called cremes tooth at
the bottom of a well you'll also see
part of a face poking out of the water
presumably belonging to a statue of some
elder God or some kind of entity worship
by the Dunwich company number 4 milton's
parking garage
remember the Saw movies remember how
badly you wanted to feel like you were
trapped in one of them but only laughs
the psychotic friends necessary to make
your dreams come true well good news
fallout 4 is Milton parking garage has
got you covered
located next to the Milton General
Hospital a labyrinthine booby-trapped
garage contains devices designed to maim
you platform puzzles and even more
mannequins placed there with the sole
purpose of giving players the
heebie-jeebies creepier than the dungeon
itself is the question that looms after
you've escaped who put this whole crazy
thing together and why and seriously
where is he getting all the mannequins
it looks like a JC Penny on a coupon day
number five in the Museum of witchcraft
one of the absolute coolest places in
all the Commonwealth is the Museum of
witchcraft and it's one you should
probably avoid if you're not armed to
the teeth you'll actually be sent here
if you pick up the quest called The
Devil's Due and decide to track down
some missing soldiers that belong to the
Gunners but it's still best to wait
until you're really ready to deal some
damage the front doors are locked tight
so you'll need to enter the building
through the basement if you have stealth
boys you'll want to use them because
you'll immediately discover that you're
not alone the building floorboards creak
and inhuman noises fill the air
experienced players will recognize the
sound as everyone's favorite monster a
deathclaw and not only does that death
cloth talk you through the Museum's
halls but around every corner you'll
encounter a bunch of spooky mannequins
meant only to raise your blood pressure
even more if you manage to avoid or kill
the Beast
you can loot a mound of death claw eggs
and you know what that means omelettes
for everyone or more accurately a whole
lot of caps and number 6 Pikmin gallery
this place will really make you wonder
whether or not you should help everyone
you meet in the Commonwealth upon
entering the Pikmin gallery you'll see a
bunch of disturbing paintings hanging on
the wall all painted with vibrant reds
and yellows
kind of like Nintendo Pikmin they all
show scenes pulled straight out of the
depths of hell or maybe just a typical
day
Five Guys Burgers and Fries we're not
quite sure more to the point you'll see
a bunch of Raiders trying to kill a man
named Pikmin should you choose to save
him he'll drop some creepy lines of
gratitude and give you a key that lets
you loot it's safe for a weapon called
pickman's blade once you really take a
look around and see all the buckets of
blood and dismembered body parts
everywhere and then think about the name
of the weapon it'll dawn on you the
Pikmin is a maniac who paints those
freakish paintings using the blood of
his victims so that answers that
question those are definitely pictures
of five guys or you know ground up in
Tendo Pikmin either way thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
tell us which fallout 4 a location put
you off solid food over the long list